hàng trong nghìn người dân tại nhà bụ quay là đang sự cạnh mất điện lúc và sợ ấm giữa được rất đất của mùa đông
sau các cuộc tấn công qua lại nhầm vào hạt tần nắng lợp
tại u quay là chính quyền kia mà một mùa thống một cho biết
hay thống điện của thủ đô đặc vụ, hả nhắc quan tòa nền xửa khẩn cấp
sau khi chúng bị thử hải nọc, bởi các đòn không kích quẩn ngài trong các đợp tập kích mùa đông
việc các điện kéo theo dõi thẩm cấp nước
sợ ấm và giáo thông công con chảy địa
trước đó khoảng một lợp sợ toàn nhà chục đưa phía đã không có sợi
khi đợp không khi lại mạnh đăng kéo như độ súng dưới âm người dổ C
có tả ngà thống đốc vùng bè của rõ giáp của quay nà cho biết
một cuộc tấn công vòng tên lợp của phía đã khiến khoảng sáo trong nghiên người mất điện lúc
và hệ thống sở niệt
giữa trức địa phương đăng lúc khôi phục các dịch dụ thiết io trong bối cảnh như độ trúng bình tại tình này
đào lắm hai độ C
tuy nhiên bị thống đốc tự nhạc tình hình cực kỳ khocan
để gồm đó để phương thường xuyên phứng chiều hỏi lực kể từ khi xung đột ngà của quay nà
lộ ra năm 2020
như độ xuống thấp trên dẫn dọng tại cảnh nhà của quay nà như ngày qua
căng làm chăm trọng thêm tất cả đồng nhân đạo từ các sự của mất điện
nước và sở ở Mỹ vý rau tranh